keine ahnung wie es ihnen geht aber ich
war selten bei einer landtagswahl so
ratlos sie diesmal hier in nrw
der letzte baut sich der letzte deutsche
der überhaupt noch wahlkampf kann
das ist unser innenminister ganzes
gesehen hier schwamm so kriegt man
aufmerksamkeit
thomas de maizière fordert eine debatte
über deutsche leitkultur moment aber die
nicht schon mal ja
lassen sie mich noch mal ganz schnell
ein haken welche das ja nicht irgendeine
leitkultur debatte nach meiner abteilung
hat die cdu damit das thema leitkultur
zum genau 500 mal aus der mottenkiste
geholt
das muss gefeiert werden
wir schalten live
danke gleich der text der betrag
einigkeit und recht und leitkultur es
ist so wichtig diese leitkultur sie ist
so wichtiger leitkultur aber für was
wichtig meinen wir haben doch
schließlich gesetze in deutschland steht
doch alles drin eben nicht sie
vaterlandslose gesellen deutsch sein
heißt eben auch ständig darüber
nachgrübeln was nun deutsch ist was ist
deutsch was hält uns solche im kern
zusammen vor allem in diesem verfluchten
jahren wo wieder em noch wm anhören
werde mit ihr macht das super wäre die
anständigen von denen die anderen ganz
viel lernen können zum beispiel wie sind
nicht locker ich habe mich oft gefragt
bin ich eigentlich bin ich gar nicht
oder hier
wir sagen unseren namen gegeben und zur
begrüßung die hand zu mühsam musste im
ausländer- wirklich alles beibringen die
einfachsten dinge bis hinauf zu dingen
der hygiene also wir putzen zu hause
auch alle unsere bäder und los wenn er
wie er sagt er seine frau
foto hab ich freue mich aber auch dass
wir sind vielleicht das europäische land
in europa endlich was wir deutschen sind
die europäischen europäer europas mit
abstand ist eine saublöde sammlung von
idiotischen allgemeinplätze nehring
natürlich gibt es bei uns
integrationsprobleme ich habe mal zu
wenig sprachkurse oder zu wenig wohnraum
ja aber die probleme zu lösen das kostet
ja geld und blödes leitkultur google
aber das gibt es umsonst das ist genial
jedes wort pures gold allgemeinbildung
hat einen wert für sich echte deutsche
haben allgemeinbildung erna welcher
waren ist der bach gestorben wie alt ihr
absatz von burkina faso gegen katheter
durch hypothese ist gras 12
[Applaus]